[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRISTOPHER SANSON:
Welcome, everybody,
to the first session
after the keynote
of Day One of Cloud Next 18.
We're very excited
to have you all here.
We appreciate a lot of
you traveled pretty far,
made a lot of
effort to get here,
and we hope that we're able
to bring you a lot of value
and improve your day
to day developer lives.
Before we get started, I think
people are still trickling in.
So one of the things
that you're going
to see new this year
at Next is we're
trying out a little something
different for the Q&A session.
So some of the larger
sessions like this one
are going to use, actually,
the same internal Q&A
system that we use at Google for
all of our large get togethers.
It's called Dory.
And if you have the
mobile app or website
and you go to this
session, you'll see a link
called the Dory Q&A.
If you click that,
you're actually going to
be able to submit questions
throughout the talk and vote
on other people's questions
so that when we get to the
Q&A session at the end,
we make sure that we answer the
questions that kind of offer
the most interest to people.
And we'll have mics as
well for people that
want to ask questions that way.
But we encourage
you to kind of check
that out and sort of
experiment, or dog food,
as we like to say, with us.
So we're here today
to talk about CI/CD
in a serverless world.
CI/CD, continuous integration
and continuous delivery.
Serverless is going to
be one of the themes
that you've heard about
already this morning,
you're going to hear about over
the course of the three days.
And serverless, I think
it's really exciting.
It's definitely one of the newer
areas of Cloud and computing.
And developer tools
around serverless
and best practices around
that are even more immature.
So we're going to talk
about some of the solutions
that we offer on Google
Cloud and some of the best
practices and
successful techniques
that we've seen in order
to run serverless workloads
in a production environment.
My name is Christopher Sanson.
I'm a product manager at Google
based out of New York City.
I work on CI/CD solutions and
developer tooling in general.
We actually have an encore
session of this talk.
It reached full enrollment.
So if you do anyone
who's interested
that wasn't able to
make it in, we're
going to have an encore
session of this on Thursday
over in the Metreon next door.
So I assume many of you
just came from the keynote.
If you did, you may have
seen the presentation
around a new business
venture that I
was thinking about starting
called The Hipster Store.
You can buy things
like old cameras,
I think, fixie bikes,
things like that.
But at Google, we're all about
openness, open platforms,
togetherness.
So The Hipster
Store didn't really
speak to me as a consumer.
So if you're not really
interested in that,
I'm actually going to
start a competing store.
It's called The Prepster Shop.
So we're going to sell things
like boat shoes and blazers.
Anything with like an
anchor or a lobster on it
is available for you there.
But one big difference
being The Hipster Shop
and the Prepster Shop is that
mine's entirely serverless.
So my front end is running
on Firebase Hosting.
My back and is
running on App Engine.
And I'm using Cloud Functions
as sort of glue code
to wrap business
logic around it.
And later on we're going to do a
demo to talk about a little bit
how this is architected
and go through kind
of the day in the
life of a developer
as I push changes
out to production.
But before we get
into that, I want
to step back just for a
second and sort of set
the stage a little bit and
kind of define serverless
as how we define it here.
Serverless is one of
those words that's
kind of like DevOps
or CI itself where,
depending on the context,
it means different things
to different people.
The way that we're
going to use serverless
is really applications
and services
that you don't really have
to think too much about what
they're running on top of.
So the idea is that you could
just bring your source code,
and you don't have to think
about versioning or patching
or provisioning or scaling.
And all of that is
really done for you.
The first thing
that typically comes
to mind when you
hear serverless is
functions, and rightfully so.
But we definitely see serverless
as a much broader ecosystem
than that.
We think it includes
things like AI
and databases and
data warehousing.
And on Google Cloud, we actually
offer serverless solutions
in each of those
different categories.
When we talk about developer
solutions in CI/CD ,
we're really mainly focused
on serverless compute.
And when we talk about
serverless compute,
there are really kind of
three primary solutions,
Google Cloud Functions,
which is relatively new,
Google App Engine, which
launched 10 years ago this year
as one of sort of the pioneers
when it comes to serverless,
and Firebase, which is kind
of part of the extended family
of the Google Cloud Platform.
So that's sort of how
we're going to talk
about serverless itself.
So when we talk about
CI/CD for serverless,
what do we mean exactly?
If you're running CI systems
now or you've built your own,
you might recognize
some of these terms.
You deal with things like
configuration management,
batch jobs, maybe ugly things
like nested virtualization
if you're trying to run
emulators for Android.
Well, these are definitely
all the things that we do not
want to worry about anymore.
We want all of these
problems to go away.
I don't want to have
to think about having
to bake an immutable
image to deploy out
to my Cloud infrastructure.
The whole point of
serverless is to kind of
move these infrastructure
pieces below the waterline
so that your developers can
focus on source code and not
this underlying infrastructure.
It would be a real shame if we
were able to move to serverless
and then our developers
had to provision a build
agent and configure it
to run their builds.
So what do we mean for
CI/CD for serverless?
Well, it's all the
best pieces of CI/CD
in the first place that helps us
lower our mean time to release,
reduce human error,
deploy faster and safer.
And for us, that primarily
revolves around automation.
So as a developer, I want to sit
in my chair, drink my iced tea,
do a git push, and
then have everything
just sort of magically deploy
out to production for me.
And along the way we're going
to have to do a couple of steps
to our code to get it there.
We might not be compiling
code, but we're probably
going to be packaging up
with something like Webpack
or something like that.
We're definitely going to want
to automate all of our unit
and integration tests.
We all have sort
of 80%, 90% test
coverage on our
applications, of course,
so we're going to want to make
sure we take advantage of that.
We're also going to want to
have a manual review process.
So if you're familiar with the
conversation between what's
continuous delivery and
what's continuous deployment--
and the difference being
that there's usually
a manual approval step--
in the real world,
almost every change
has to be reviewed by
somebody before it goes out.
Whether it's a product owner
or management or design team,
we're going to want to
bake that into our process
that somebody can look at
and say OK, this looks good.
This is what we had in mind.
We're also going
to take advantage
of some of the best practices
around continuous delivery,
so things like blue green
deployments and canary.
And this is really to reduce
downtime to our users,
and also minimize
the blast radius
of any errors that do get out.
We're not going to want
to deploy something
to 100% of users right away.
We're going to canary it out
gradually, sort of 5%, 10%
at a time.
The last couple, as
we go through these,
we're going to want to
automate related tasks,
so things like creating
documentation and stuff
that we often tend to forget.
And the last is consistent
build environments.
And this is just a
general best practice
around developer tools.
I think we all
know the phenomenon
of building locally and
then building in the Cloud
and not having
those two match up
and trying to figure out why.
So if we look at this
kind of flowchart,
this probably looks
familiar to most of you.
This is sort of a classic
software delivery lifecycle
chart.
As a developer, I'm
going to do a git push.
My source code is
then going to get
packaged and tested
and then deployed
to a staging environment.
From there we're
going have a chance
to review and promote
that to production,
and ultimately deliver
it to our users.
So when we talk about CI/CD,
it's more of a spectrum.
It's more of a staircase than
it is like a light switch.
We did a recent research asking
people, do you practice CI/CD?
And one of the questions
we asked, do you
practice true CI and true CD?
And only about 15% of
organizations said they did.
The vast majority were
self-described as well,
we do kind of almost CI/CD.
We sort of do true CD, but
we sort of almost do CI.
We kind of fake it
around the edges.
So what we find is
that most companies who
are trying to move towards
full end-to-end automation
are still in that journey
and still getting there.
So if you look at the basic--
and this is in red because this
isn't really even
part of CI/CD--
but particularly in the
context of serverless,
we're tempted to do
manual deployments.
If I'm changing a single file
or changing an HTML file,
what's the big deal?
I can just run a deploy script.
I can go to my terminal.
Most of these have really
powerful CLI tools.
I can just manually deploy.
But pretty quickly
as a developer,
I hit a wall with that.
If I have any sort of team
that's developing together
on a source repo, if I
want to reduce errors,
I'm going to want to
sort of step up my game.
And so particularly in the
context of CI/CD, what we see
is that a lot of the services,
more and more frequently,
are coming with baked in smarts.
So a lot of the best
practices, like things
like traffic splitting, that
we had to sort of create
ourselves and code, are
coming as baked in features
of the platform itself.
And I think what we're
going to see over
time is that more and more
of these best practices
come supported out of the
box, so that every time you
do a deployment, you can
provide the test script to run,
you can tell the branch of your
repo that you want to trigger.
But we're not really there yet.
So I think as we said,
serverless tools are still
relatively new.
It's still an evolving space.
So this is definitely
where we're going to go,
but in terms of
building a pipeline,
we can't really do it quite yet.
So the next step up is
what I kind of think
of as devcentric CI/CD.
And so in this world, it's
very developer-focused.
As a developer, I want to
live in my source code.
I want to live in
my code editor.
I want to live at the terminal.
I want to make changes, and
then again, I want my changes
to go out to production.
Services in this
kind of category,
they're generally hosted.
They're generally
pretty easy to use.
And in this role, I really view
my repo as my source of truth.
I want to be able
to go to my git repo
and get a pretty
good sense of what
users are seeing at each
stage of the environment.
And the final step on the ladder
is kind of opcentric CI/CD.
So as we talk to customers,
particularly larger ones
in enterprises, the
devcentric model
tends to fall over
at some point.
So larger customers tend to be--
they have very complex and
heterogeneous footprints,
and they're always
kind of migrating
between multiple services.
So they may have some
sort of legacy platform
that's running on prem.
They're probably deploying
to multiple clouds.
They may be deploying to
Kubernetes and VMs and Windows
and Linux and iOS.
And operators who are
trying to put out fires
all the time, really,
they just want
like a single pane of
glass view across all
of these different deployments.
And they also want to
enforce compliance as well.
They want to have
that bottleneck
so that they can enforce
security and compliance rules
across deployments everywhere.
And in that category, if you're
familiar, worked with Google,
you may have heard
about Spinnaker.
I know many of you here are
actually using it already.
Spinnaker is an open source,
multi-Cloud continuous delivery
platform.
It's co-developed by
Google and Netflix.
And we have a couple
of great talks
that really dive deeper
into that this week.
Target is giving one.
Netflix is actually
here as well.
They're giving a talk with Waze
about how they use Spinnaker.
But for the purpose
of this talk,
we're really going to focus
on the devcentric experience.
And because we're
talking about serverless,
the lines between these
categories blur even more.
So we sort of talked about we
want to hide the operations
piece from our developers.
And serverless really
lets us do that.
So we really want to achieve
full automation from the source
repo.
So I think our first
takeaway, as I hope
we all sort of appreciate--
I imagine we're here in the
room because we generally
agree on this--
is that you absolutely still
need CI/CD solutions built
around this.
And so at Google, this is what
we're excited to announce.
So this week, and
earlier this morning,
you heard that we
announced Cloud Build.
So Google Cloud Build is
a hosted CI/CD platform
running on Google Cloud for
automating your developer
workloads.
And this is actually an
evolution of another Google
product, Container Builder.
So to give a brief history, if
you're familiar with Container
Builder, we launched this
a year ago at GCP Next 17
as a way to build docker
images quickly and easily.
You could point it at a
repo and do a git push,
and we would upload your source
code to a VM in the Cloud
that we managed, do a docker
build, and push that out
to container registry.
But from the very beginning,
the way we architected this,
we sort of had grander visions.
We thought, there's a lot
more we can do with this
than just build containers.
We can really apply this
to not only containers,
but other workflows as well.
So let's take a look at of
how a workflow at Cloud Build
actually works.
And we can talk a little bit how
about it applies to serverless.
So we start as we always
do with source code.
And in the case
of containers, we
end up with a built image
in the Container Registry.
And along the way, we upload
your source code to the Cloud,
to Google, and we put it
in a shared file system.
And against that
workspace, we're
going to run a series
of build steps.
So build steps are
the naming convention
that Cloud Build uses.
It's sort of like
stages or jobs,
if you're familiar with that
from other CI solutions.
And in the context
of containers,
you may do things like this.
You may do a docker pull to
fetch a previously built image.
You may fetch some
dependencies, do a docker build,
and then push that
out to the registry.
But the key takeaway, or the
key way to look at Cloud Build
and why it's different is that
these build steps are actually
just containers themselves.
So everything that
happens in a Cloud Build
is a containerized task
that's completely isolated
and completely defined
by you as the user.
So because of that,
people pretty quickly,
with Container Builder,
said hey, wait a minute,
I can do a lot more.
I can run all sorts of different
things in the container.
And so very quickly they
started doing things
like building other
types of artifacts.
So they were doing
gradle and maven builds
to build [INAUDIBLE] and
binaries, pushing that up
to Cloud storage.
They started running tests.
You could run
arbitrary bash scripts,
you can do curl, things
like even Docker Compose.
A Kubernetes user said,
well, I built the image
and I have it on my worker.
Instead of pushing
to a registry,
can I just kind of
do a git ops model?
Can I use kube CTL or Helm to
apply that out to the cluster?
And they started
using it that way.
And I think what we also saw,
and the reason we're here,
is that it works really great
for serverless applications.
And that's because I think
one of the coolest parts
about serverless is that
almost all of the best services
come with really
great CLI tools.
So things like, sure, G
Cloud and Firebase, but even
throughout the ecosystem,
things like Netlify and Surge
and Web Task.
They all come with
really powerful CLIs
that really naturally
extend themselves
into containerized workloads.
And so what you can do is not
only build and test your code,
but also deploy it
out to serverless.
We call these things
builder images,
and these are the actual
containerized tasks
that you can use to run
your different workloads.
And these are all open source.
And you can, of
course, bring your own.
I think we have around
40 or 50 that are
contributed by the community.
And people have done
all sorts of things.
We have some for .NET.
There's an Android builder.
There's Packer.
There's Hugo.
You name it, and
just about anything
can be run as a container task.
So the second takeaway is that
not only do we really want
to still do CI/CD
for serverless,
but that you could use
Cloud Build as well
for that solution.
And in fact, that's actually
exactly what we're going to do.
So let's switch back
over to our demo,
and we're going to look
at the Prepster Store
here and see if we can't
go through a couple
real world examples of actually
making changes and then
deploying this out.
So if we could
switch to the demo .
Great.
Thank you.
So let's look at our site here.
So this is our Prepster Shop.
This is live and up on the
web and ready for business.
And what we did is we
created two environments.
So first we created a
staging environment,
both on Firebase, which is here,
and a production environment.
And all of our changes,
before hitting prod,
are going to pass through
our staging environment.
And if we look at
our source repo,
we'll see that we are using
sort of a small mono repo.
So obviously we could
use microservices.
But for the sake of
keeping things simple,
we decided to put
everything in one place,
so we have a back
end folder here,
which is an App Engine app,
front end running on Firebase,
and Cloud Functions.
So the site is looking
pretty good to me.
But I got in on the morning.
I'm enjoying my
first cup of coffee.
And the design team
comes running over,
and they say, hey, look,
the site looks really great.
We really like this
header bar, but we really
need to update it.
The red color, it's
looking a little stale.
We really want to
turn this to green.
So I said sure.
That is no problem.
So I'm going to go back
here to my source code,
go into the front end.
This is an AngularJS app.
Go into source, find the CSS
file where that's defined,
and make my change.
So it's here, red.
Let's make it green.
Commit that.
So I'm going to commit that in.
I'm now going to jump
over the Cloud Build UI.
So this is the Cloud
Build UI in Cloud Console.
This is now a top level service,
so you'll find it directly
under Tools, and
it's no longer nested
under Container Registry, if
you're familiar with that.
And if I hit refresh,
I'll see that a new
build was kicked off.
So if I jump into that
build, we can take a look
at what's happening.
So this build was kicked off
by my trigger, deploy front end
to staging.
It's in progress.
I'm using some encrypted
secrets for my Firebase
token for my ultimate
deployment to Firebase.
And I'm going to run a
series of build steps here.
So first I'm going to install my
node modules using NPM install,
and then I'm going
to do a simple build
using NPM run build.
And then I'm just
going to deploy it out
with the regular Firebase
CLI doing Firebase deploy
to my staging environment.
And if I look at the
trigger that set this up,
I'll go over here.
So this is the trigger.
It's a Cloud Build
trigger, and this
is what the logic that looks
for events on my repo and then
kicks off the pipeline
that I created.
So for this one I'm going to
listen to changes on my staging
branch and only changes
that happen in my front end
directory.
So you saw that we set
it up as a mono repo.
If I make a change
to my back end,
I obviously don't want
to rebuild and deploy
my front end.
I only want to deploy
changes that are relevant.
So this is a new
feature of Cloud Build
that's available as of today.
We call it file path triggering.
And it lets you filter triggers
basically on files that change.
So we're going to look for
changes in our front end
folder, and we're actually going
to ignore some other files.
So if I change the
read me or git ignore,
I don't want to trigger
a build on that either.
So we're going to ignore
any changes to those.
And then when that
happens, we're
just going to use
our Cloud Build.YAML
to configure our build.
So if I go back over
here to the build,
check in on the progress,
and I fight the Wi-Fi,
we'll see that OK, the build
is successfully completed.
And if I go back to my staging
app and refresh, sure enough,
we see that my change was
successfully deployed.
So I talk to the design team.
I say, does this look good?
They say, yep, looks great.
So when you go back
to my git repo here.
Looks like GitHub
was nice enough
to recommend the
pull request for me.
I'm going to create this.
And what I'm doing now to
promote it to production
is simply merge it
into my master branch.
So I'm going to
merge this, confirm.
Great.
So now this change
was on my master.
And I'm obviously
working from the UI
here just so I don't have to
go through the full workflow.
But obviously,
from your terminal,
you can do a git commit and git
push to invoke this as well,
or use plug-ins with
your code editor.
And if I go back to
Cloud Build, I'll
see another build
has been kicked off,
which again, will do more
or less the same steps.
But this time we're deploying
to production instead.
So if we look at
the Cloud Build.YAML
to get a bit better sense
of exactly how we set this
up, let's go to front end, look
at the Cloud Build.YAML that
executed, we're going
to see more or less
the same build steps
that we saw before.
So this first one we're
installing our node modules.
This is the containerized
task that we're running.
So we're going to
use NPM and we're
going to pass in our arguments
and just run NPM install.
And we're going to do this
in the front end directory.
We have a couple other steps
for linting and code testing
that we're just commenting
out for the sake of the demo,
but we would probably
run these as well.
We're then going to
build with NPM run build
and then simply
deploy with Firebase.
And it comes with
built-in support for KMS,
which is key
management service, so
that you can encrypt your
tokens to talk to third party
services.
So if we go back to the
build, one other thing
that you might have noticed,
if you're using Container Build
or that you haven't
seen yet, is view
this build in the new
Build Result interface.
So if we click on that
and fight the Wi-Fi--
whoa.
That is not a feature.
The demo gods were kind.
Here we go.
So this is our new
build result UI.
And you can see that we're
running the same build
that we ran before.
So we have steps where we
install our node modules,
run our builds, and deploy.
And this is currently
in private alpha,
but this is going to be
rolling out later this year.
And what we heard from
users over and over
was that the UI is really
great, but as a developer,
I really want to be able
to debug my builds quickly
and also have more
of a dashboard
view of what the status of my
different deployed applications
are.
So we're building a new UI from
scratch to help enable that.
So if I look here,
it says that looks
like this build was successful.
And if I go back to production
here and refresh, sure enough,
my change is out and I'm done.
So I send a Slack message to
the design team that says,
good news, our changes are live.
So I'm feeling good.
I'm going back to my coffee.
And before I can relax too much,
I see the sales team runs over.
The sales team
runs over and says,
hey, Christopher,
good news, bad news.
The good news is
the linen blazer
has been extremely popular.
The bad news is that we're sold
out, so we don't have any left.
And can we update the
database to indicate that
so that we don't get any more
orders before we get more in?
So we say sure, no problem.
So for that we're going
to jump into our back end.
So if we go back
to our repo here,
this is just a regular
App Engine app.
We've created two
versions of it,
one for staging, which we're
going to deploy to our staging
service, and one to
production, which we're just
going to use our default. And
if we jump into our App JS
and find out where our API
response is coming from--
this is our fancy inventory
management service here--
turn this to true.
Commit to staging.
There we go.
And if we go back to Cloud
Build again, refresh,
we'll see that a new
build has been kicked off.
This one is triggering on
deploy back into staging,
so again, we're looking only for
changes to our back end folder.
And this one's pretty simple.
We're just running basically
a gcloud app deploy
to our staging service.
One thing that's interesting
that you'll notice here
is that we're actually going
to pass in a version ID.
So if you're familiar
with App Engine,
if you don't specify
one, App Engine
will provide you
with a unique ID.
But it doesn't really
tell you much about what
was actually deployed.
So we're actually going to pass
in the commit SHA as our ID
to all of our App
Engine deployments.
And this way, if we go to
our App Engine interface
and want to understand
what's in production
or what's on staging, we can
really quickly and easily map
it back to the commit
SHA so we know exactly
what source code was in there.
So if we let that change
go out, looks like the
build is completing,
and it's done.
I will go over here,
refresh, and let's see.
App Engine can be fairly
efficient with its caching
sometimes.
So if I go to the
API response and give
that a chance to refresh here.
And OK, so sold out is true.
So we should see that as
well on our front end now.
And we do.
So our linen blazer here
is transferred to sold out
and I can no longer buy it.
Looks good to me.
It's a pretty
straightforward change.
So let's do the same
trick we did before.
Let's go back to our code repo.
Let's merge this into
master and push that out.
And so for our
push to production,
we're actually going to do a
little something different.
So we talked earlier about how
we want to canary changes out
to users and not necessarily
deploy them to 100% of people
all at once.
And if we go in here
to our build and we
look at the build
steps that ran,
we're doing some
more things here.
So let's look at
our Cloud Build.YAML
and investigate a little
further out what's going on.
So we're going to
go to our Cloud
Build.YAML for production.
And what we're going to do
is actually-- so the way
App Engine works is that
when you do a deployment
and you give it
your source code,
it actually builds a
container under the hood
using Cloud Build
itself, and then deploys
that container out.
So when we're deploying
in production,
we're actually going to do
this process ourself manually.
Instead of deploying
source code,
we're going to build the
container ahead of time
and then pass that in.
So this way I actually
now have an artifact
of what was released
at any time.
So if anything ever goes
wrong in production,
I could pull that container
down and run it locally.
I can also use it for things
like integration tests
and smoke tests and
things like that.
So we're going to do NPM test,
we're going to do docker build,
and then we're going to use the
image URL flag to deploy it out
to App Engine.
The other thing that
we're going to do
is we're actually going
to canary this change out.
So we're going to use
the no promote flag
to deploy the version but not
actually send any traffic over
yet.
And what we're
going to do here is
we're going to actually do
a little of scripting here.
So everything we've
done so far has
been pretty straightforward,
like Firebase deploy, G Cloud
App deploy.
For canary now, we're
going to jump into Bash.
So this is a container.
I can just set my entry
point to anything I want.
And we're going to grab
the version that users
are currently seeing.
So we're going to do G
Cloud App versions list,
sort it by the amount of
traffic that it's getting,
and just grab the first one.
We're then going to have a
really very pretty Python
script to grab that
version ID and then
use the Cloud set traffic
field to programmatically
canary this change out.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to take the
version that we just
deployed, which we tagged to the
commit SHA, and give that 5%.
We're then going to
take the version that's
currently getting traffic
and give that 95%.
And so if we go over to App
Engine here and hit refresh,
sure enough, we'll
see that the build
that we just did is
currently being rolled out
to 5% of our users.
And what's great is that
App Engine comes baked
in with things like
traffic splitting.
So we can go in here, and then
assuming things look good,
roll this out as we see fit.
So we're just going to
roll it out to 100%.
So that was saved successfully.
And if we go back, we'll see
that we have successfully
canaried this change out.
So let's just confirm
here that actually worked.
Yes.
And sure enough, it's
in production and live.
All right.
So if we take a little breath
and just look at everything
we just accomplished, with just
a couple of changes to our git
repo, we're able to
stage and deploy changes
to both our front
end and our back end.
And if you notice, we were
jumping around in the UI
to show you what was going
on behind the scenes.
But really, as a
developer, I never
really had to leave
my code editor.
I could just do all
this from the terminal.
I could do all this from
GitHub or the source repository
that you're using, and just
push those changes out and not
have to worry about anything.
So we're feeling pretty good.
I was going to take a break.
But I see the CEO
is running over.
The CEO comes over, and we had
previously set up an alert.
So every time we made a
large sale, as a startup,
we're very excited.
We set it up so that
she gets a text message,
so that she got this
gong in the office,
and every time we
have a big sale,
she likes to go and ring
the gong and celebrate.
Turns out she got a new
phone number over the weekend
and really needs us
to update where we're
sending those text messages to.
So for that, we're going
to jump back into our code
and go into Cloud Functions.
So Cloud Functions is
definitely one of the things
that we hear from
customers the most about,
how do I run functions or
manage functions at scale?
Like when I have one
function or two functions,
it's pretty straightforward, but
if I start getting 50 or 100,
how can I automate
this in a safe way?
I don't want to have to
manually update my index.js file
every time I create
a new one, and I
don't want to deploy all my
functions every single time
I make a change.
So we're going to do a couple
of things via convention
and a couple of
things via technology
here to make sure
that this works.
So the first thing
we're going to do
is we're going to put our
functions in this functions
folder here.
And so these are our functions.
On large sale is the
one we care about.
But we have a whole bunch.
So we have auth log in log
out, user on create on delete.
And if you notice that we added
an extension here to each one
of these .f.js, and this is
going to let us do some kind
of fancy stuff.
So if we go to
our index.js file,
we're going to do a
couple of tricks here.
Some you may be familiar
with, some may be new.
So the way functions
works is that it
looks for exported functions
in your index.js file.
And we're going
to do is actually
glob over that functions
folder, grab every file that
ends in f.js, and
then we're going
to loop over it and convert that
file path to a function name.
So in the case of
auth on create,
we're going to convert
that to a camel case
to a function name
called auth on create.
And then we're actually
going to create
two versions of every function.
So for every function
that we have,
we're going to create
one regular version, auth
on create, and one for staging.
So we're going to append
an underscore staging
to every single function
as well and make
both of these
available to ourselves.
So we go back to our code here.
And let's go ahead and make that
change and see what happens.
So I go in here, and we're using
Twilio to send an SMS message.
And I'm going to
update the phone number
and commit that out.
And if I go over to
Cloud Build, hit refresh,
there's our new build.
We're going to jump in.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to do this function
called deploy updated functions.
So let's look at the Cloud Build
and see what's happening here.
So you see again, we're
doing the same steps.
We're going to use yarn this
time to do yarn install.
We have some unit tests
that we've commented out.
So what we're going to
do is we're actually
going to create a cached
version of all the functions
that we deploy and put
it up in Cloud storage.
And then every time
we do a deployment,
we're going to recursively loop
over that functions folder,
look for changes, and deploy
only those files that changed.
So we could walk through
that a little bit.
So the first step is
we're going to grab
our functions.staging
folder from the Cloud
and look at what functions
are currently live in staging.
We're then going to
do a diff and loop
over comparing our local
function changes to the changes
that are out in staging.
We're going to use this .n flag
to look for new files as well
that we've introduced.
And then for each
file that's different,
we're going to convert that
file path to a name again using
our camel case convention, and
then just deploy that function
out, this time to staging.
And we're going to pass in
our environment variables
using KMS again for Twilio.
So if we look at our build,
see how that's coming along,
then we can go on here,
we can look at logs.
We can reverse these.
So looks like it's deployed.
Looks like it just finished.
And if we go to Cloud
Functions, so this
is what it looks like when
I've deployed all my functions.
So for every function that we
had, authOnLogin, authLogout,
we have two versions,
staging and prod.
And if we hit refresh, we'll
notice that of the ones
that these deployed, only this
one, on large sale staging,
was updated recently.
So we didn't have to deploy
any of the other functions.
And as you get to scale
with hundreds of functions.
This becomes really nice.
So we just deployed the
only one that changed.
And if we liked how that went.
We can go back and
again, do the same thing,
merge that into master and
then deploy that out as well.
So now this is just going
to go ahead and roll out
to production.
And our CEO will successfully
get all text message updates
and be able to celebrate
our wins with our team.
Great.
So that's more or less our demo.
As a developer, I
was able to pretty
quickly and easily, in, about 10
or 20 minutes push changes out
to Firebase App Engine and
Cloud Functions with little
to no effort outside
of just doing
a simple git to push deploy.
So if we go back to
the presentation,
this was all done
with Cloud Build.
And so with Cloud
Build, just real quickly
we're going to go through
some of the new features that
are available today that
we used in the demo.
It's top level in
the Cloud console,
so you'll see it there.
We're adding support for
first class artifacts.
So the same way that
you could push images
to a Container Registry,
you can now push artifacts
to Cloud storage.
So if we're building
things like binaries
or just regular folders.
We added support for
file path triggers,
which we used pretty
extensively in order to filter
based on sub directory.
And then we have
two new changes that
are currently in
private alpha but are
going to be coming soon.
This one is probably the one I'm
most excited about and the one
that we hear from
customers the most,
is a deeper integration
with GitHub itself.
So we're adding native built-in
support for pull requests,
posting status back
to the new checks
API, as well as the ability
to programmatically create
triggers via the API.
So instead of having
to go to the UI
if you're creating lots
and lots of triggers,
you can do it now via the API.
And that's all going
to be rolling out soon,
is available in alpha.
And then last is the new
result UI that we showed.
So why Cloud Build
for serverless?
It's serverless, too, kind of.
We didn't really have
to provision anything.
We didn't really have to think
about what it was running on.
We just submitted a
Cloud Build.YAML file.
It's pay as you go.
It's a pretty good free tier.
It's 120 free minutes a day.
The builds, particularly
for serverless,
were one or two minutes long.
So this is a pretty good deal.
It's highly configurable.
You can bring your
own container,
you can run your own tasks.
And it's developer friendly.
So everything we showed
was running in the Cloud.
But it actually comes with
the local binary, Cloud Build
Local, so you can run
builds on your workstation
and you can trigger
builds from API or SDK.
So if we go back to
our flow diagram here,
I think we showed doing a
git pushed through staging.
And we were able to use
Cloud Build in order
to improve your
developer velocity
and increase faster and safer
deployments to serverless run
times like App Engine, Cloud
Functions, and Firebase.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]